[Applause]
welcome everyone to the Union Chapel and
to intelligence squar it is so fabulous
to be back with all of you in the hall
not on a computer there are however
people watching online so hello to you
thank you for joining in the very fact
that uh we're all here tonight is proof
enough isn't it that we've already made
at least one intelligent decision in a
chaotic World added to which I haven't
arrived with a suitcase full of wine or
indeed a karaoke machine uh and I know
we'll all be polite to the security
staff and the cleaners um our decision
making so far has been impeccable but uh
this evening's conversation May reveal
that perhaps not all of our decisions
are as sound as we'd like to believe our
confidence in our own expertise may be
misplaced and our judgments may be
flawed so without further Ado let me
introduce our speakers Daniel kman
probably doesn't need much of an
introduction he's a Nobel Prize winner
and the author of The hugely influential
International bestseller thinking fast
and slow and his day job is as professor
of psychology and public affairs at
Princeton University um Professor
caraman is of course here to talk about
his new book noise a flaw in human
judgment and I'm delighted to say that
we're also joined by one of his
co-authors Olivier bourney who is
Professor of strategy and business
policy at H Paris previously he was a
senior partner at McKenzie and he's also
the author of you're about to make a
terrible mistake well I hope we're not
about to do that right now so um before
we really get going I just want to
remind you that I want all of you to get
involved both in the hall and at home
online uh there's a chance for lots of
q&as at towards the end after about an
hour or so there will be microphones
down here at the front and up there
please come forward I would love to hear
from you all and if you're online there
is a sort of a a bit at the bottom of
the screen as it were uh you can ask
questions in the in the Box just beneath
the screen type them in we want to hear
from you get thinking and uh I'll make
sure there's plenty of time for
questions from
everyone let's get going then noise
fresan basic definitions what is noise
well noise has many meanings but the
noise that we're talking about is
Judgment
noise and judgment noise is variability
that shouldn't exist it's when people
make judgments that should be identical
because they're
about the same subject but they turn out
to be variable and and there is a lot of
noise and our statement about this is
that wherever there is Judgment there is
noise and there is a lot more than you
think and you know that's really what
the book is about and there is more
noise Than People expect to see and how
is that different from what we think of
as bias well to draw the distinction
sharply between noise and bias we we
have to see what we have to talk about
what judgment is and the way we think
about judgment is we think of judgment
as a species of
measurement where the measuring
instrument is the human mind and like
other measurements you deal with a
subject an object topic and you assign
that topic of value on a scale and this
is what Jud the kind of judgment that we
talk about is we talk about really
judgments about specific
topics now in measurement there is a
theory of measurement that is a basic
Theory you know that serves uh all the
sciences and there is a of course a
theory of Errors of measurement so when
you measure you make take a physical
measurement uh say of a line with a very
very fine ruler and you take repeated
measurements of the length of the same
lines uh then what's going to happen is
this you're not going to get the same
result every time if the the ruler is
fine enough uh and that variability that
is noise but there is another kind of
error and this is that every measurement
is likely to be an error an overestimate
or an underestimate and the average
error is called bias and this is really
those are the meanings of bias and noise
that we use in discussing judgment so
bias is an average systematic error and
noise is just a variability of judgments
and it's a variability that shouldn't
exist so Olivier why are we all so so
much more familiar with the idea of bias
is it the sort of sexy cousin of noisy
well it's sexier it's more visible so a
way to think about the definition Danny
gave which is perhaps more visual is to
imagine that you've got a team of
Shooters shooting at a Target they're
all using the same rifle and they're all
shooting at the same Target and you look
at the Target after they all took their
shot and if you see that they all hit
the bullseye you say great they're
accurate now if you see that they've all
hit the same place but that place is not
the bullseye you immediately say this
calls for an explanation there must be a
reason there's something wrong with the
rifle or there is something wrong with
the Target or somebody moved the Target
or maybe the wind is blowing really hard
you immediately look for a c that's why
bias is sexier as you say right because
bias is something you can explain you
can point the finger at the reason why
these people all made the same mistake
if by contrast you see your five or six
shooters shooting all over the place you
just shrug and say Well they're not
great marksmen but that doesn't give you
an urge to explain so noise is more
random by definition and is less easy to
spot when you see it I'm still curious
about why we haven't thought about this
more systematically in the way that you
do in the book is it that in a sense
people in general just have too much
confidence in their judgment in their
decision making well you know it would
be an exaggeration to say that people
have not thought about it U people have
looked at reliability of judgment for a
long time what I think Justified writing
the noise writing the book
was with the pre well the prevalence
just a sheer amount of noise and for
that possibly an example would use
absolutely why should we worry about it
I'd like to tell the story of how the
study began and and the study
began number of years ago when I was
doing a consulting job at uh at an
insurance company and I had the idea of
running what we now would call a noise
audit but it's really a fairly standard
exercise of
constructing problems that were typical
underwriting problems quite realistic
and having multiple
Underwriters put a dollar value on the
same
risk and of course you wouldn't expect
these people to
agree but I asked the executives if you
take two under writers at random by how
much do you expect them to vary in
percentages of and and that question it
turns out has an answer and without
asking asking you I think we know what
number is in your mind because we've
we've asked that question of a large
number of people and the number is
roughly 10% people think that 10% is a
reasonable difference between people we
know that they won't agree perfectly
because it's a matter of judgment and
judgment is defined by the possibility
of reasonable disagreement but we expect
a limited amount of noise it turned
out that the difference the the average
difference between two Underwriters was
50% wow five times larger than the
executives expected and that is really
the reason for writing the book is that
there was so much more noise Than People
expected and this came as a complete
surprise to their
organization and Olivier soon joined and
we worked together on on that
topic and it turns out that it's not
only in the insurance company but
wherever you look at judgment you find
noise and a lot of it and there's also a
misunderstanding which explains why
people have paid less attention to it
the misunderstanding is the the
misconception that it doesn't matter
because on average it cancels out right
noise is an error of average zero
essentially and people tend to say well
we care about bias because bias is the
shared error but we don't care about
noise because on average it cancels out
of course that's wrong right if you
think of the underwriters if on average
they price correctly but sometimes they
price way too low and sometimes it's way
too high well when it's way too low the
company is going to lose money by paying
too much in claims and when it's way too
high is going to lose money by losing
business to a competitor so both
mistakes are costly but when we think of
Noise We tend to think that well average
errors you on average errors cancel out
they
don't and that's what we want wanted to
draw attention to so so it is about in a
business context and we can come back to
some more examples but in a business
context there is money at stake
essentially is what you're saying it's a
financial cost oh absolutely it's a Mis
it's an error what I actually the a
notion I I should have mentioned earlier
from the theory of measurement is that
in the theory of measurement noise and
bias are equally important in fact there
is a Formula the ma the mathematics
don't matter but the formula is that a
measure of global inaccuracy is the
square of the bias plus the square of
the noise and that's just to give you an
idea that bias and noise are independent
sources of inaccuracy and in principle
equally important in practice we think
there is more noise than bias in
judgment it has a cost as you point out
but it's not just about the business
cost another example which we looked at
is Justice Criminal Justice and when you
give the same cases this is an old study
that was done in the US we're not aware
of it being done anywhere else including
here but I'm sure the results would be
very similar if you give the same cases
simplified cases vignettes to multiple
experienced judges you will find a lot
of variability in their judgments for
some of those cases you will find some
judges saying one you're in prison and
others saying like in prison for some of
these cases you will find some judges
saying 15 years in prison and others
saying no prison at all on average for a
sentence of seven years you have almost
four years of difference between two
judges again looking at the same case
we're not talking about individualized
sentencing you taking care of the
specifics of each situation that is
already in the case we're talking about
different judges looking at the same
case this is not a business cost but
this is a huge problem of fairness
and one of the big consequences of noise
is unfairness the thing that I found
fascinating about that particular
example was that it had been recognized
in a proper study mandatory guidelines
were put in place and then they were
taken they there was so much the judges
were so unhappy that they became
advisory it's it's slightly more
complicated in fact it was a long battle
led by a judge called Franco in the US
and then by Ted Kennedy when he was
Senator which led to establishing
guidelines that Define rather precisely
what sentencing should be with some
leeway to adjust to the situation and
the possibility of going out of the
guidelines if you Justified it Etc and
then for technical reasons that have
nothing to do with what we're discussing
here the Supreme Court turned those
guidelines into advisory guidelines and
noise crept back in it's not because the
judges were unhappy about them but the
judges were unhappy but but they were
unhappy and as soon as they could
actually regain their discretion they
used it to the full extent that they
could
discussing noise with judges is quite an
interesting exercise because the you
know the whole idea is there is this is
a justice system Justice is being
determined as being me of to defendants
and the idea that there is noise in that
system is acceptable to to the extent
that I was actually invited to talk to a
large group of Judges but what they what
the organizers asked me to talk about
was noise in
medicine so uh noise drilling noise in
Justice is quite quite complex but
actually noise in medicine sorry carry
on but what's the noise in medicine
there is a lot of noise in medicine uh
about as much noise as as wherever there
is Judgment there is noise and so this
is true for diagnosis this is true for
treatment uh in in some cases it really
is quite shocking we had uh a set of
data sent to us from Harvard Medical
School on the diagnosis of epilepsy from
EG recordings and the average
correlation between two physicians in
judging cases is not exactly zero but
not much higher than zero and in
negative I think I if I recall correctly
I think it was a small negative number
no wasn't it I I don't think I remember
it as slightly positive but Cas in
either case it was very
small adding adding to that view that
medicine is an art rather than a science
but so far I mean these are decisions
that are made repeatedly so if you go
back to the judge or the the doctor
indeed that they're making similar
decisions over and over again does it
apply to oneoff decisions can you talk
talk about noise in in singular
decisions well we we ask ourselves that
question because obviously when we
measure a noise we me we when we Define
no we Define it as variability between
multiple decisions that should be
identical that definition does not apply
to a decision that you make only once
but when we look at the things that
cause noise which we haven't talked
about yet the the psychological
mechanisms behind noise it's very clear
that they're also present when you make
one of those one of life or death
momentus change the world decisions you
know brexit or no brexit is there noise
in that decision well if you think that
it's a judgment that is being made by a
human being there must be because the
same causes that create noise out there
we we came to think of those singular
decisions those unique decisions as
repeated decisions that happen only once
right if they were repeated you would
actually see that there is noise in them
you can't see it but that doesn't mean
there isn't noise so so let's talk about
the causes of noise I mean why do three
judges facing very similar cases make
three different decisions or three
doctors looking at the same x-ray come
to three different conclusions well
there are several sources of noise
actually there are three main sources of
noise and one source of noise is
differences consistent differences
between noise in between judges in the
of the judgments they make so some
judges will be more severe than others
so on average their sentences the
sentences of one judge will be higher
than the other this is well known this
is quite recognized there is another
source of noise which is also we is not
surprising to people and this is noised
within a judge that is the same judge uh
in a good mood or in a bad mood it turns
out on a sunny day or an rainy day and a
hot day or a cooler day will pass make
somewhat different judgments we call
that occasion noise but then there is a
third source of noise which turns out to
be the most important and and I would
call that it's a difference in the
almost in personality if you
will that and to see it in the decisions
in the Justice context
if you take sever if you take two
judges and you show them 20 cases the
new type of noise is that they will not
order the cases in terms of severity in
the same way so you might have one judge
who is particularly shocked by uh when
you know the defendants are uh young or
when the victims are old and and there
are differences in taste you can have a
judge who is strongly affected by
someone was similar to to a member of
their family and that is that would be
consistent and we call that pattern
noise and it turns out that pattern
noise is the more important the more
interesting and the most difficult kind
type of noise so pattern noise is not
quite like group think is it where a
group works but does that affect noise
as well
then group well let's clarify patter
noise first okay go clarify P noise yes
so
p and that touches on something that you
mentioned
earlier that when people look at the
world or at any problem in the world uh
you have the sense every one of us had
the sense that we see the world the way
we do because that's the way it is so we
have the sense that we're in touch with
reality and if the world is as we see it
we expect other reasonable people to see
it in the same way and it turns out that
they don't to an extent that is
radically surprising so what what we
have to take on board here is is the
idea that people are really more
different from each other in how they
see any problem in the world than any of
them would expect and that's the basic
phenomenon of no and we also have to
come to grips with the idea that that's
not good news
when when we say oh we're all different
we we're all unique we're all diverse we
have different views on everything we
usually celebrate that we say that's
beautiful that's diversity that's where
creativity comes from that's where
Innovation comes from but the thing is
when you go to one doctor and he says
you have this and then you go to another
doctor and he says you have that you
don't say oh beautiful
creativity Innovation diversity no you
say one of you guys must be wrong
perhaps both by the way so when we think
there is a correct answer which is how
we Define judgment that kind of
diversity is what we call pattern noise
the fact that people project their own
history and their own sensibilities and
their own biases on a situation is what
creates this pattern noise and it's not
good
news isn't that what people call human
agency it is what people call projecting
their personality into their judgment
and of course if you expect them to do
that that's beautiful if you are
choosing whom to marry in that way
congratulations that's how I would
strongly recommend you do it if you're
making a hiring decision on behalf of
the BBC we might have a
problem so to go back to the the earlier
point then if you have a meeting and the
first person stands up and says I
definitely want to do it this way uh you
know I definitely think we should only
employ people who wear red t-shirts and
the second person gets up and says or
are they more likely to to make the same
decision how do people affect one
another how does that create noise
groups tend to create noise in just the
way that you said in that when you want
to minimize noise or to reduce noise
then you want the judgments of people to
be independent of each other so you
would want witnesses to the same crime
to discuss their testimony before they
give it and this is precisely what
happens in a meeting in a meeting people
influence each other and the first
person to speak has a disproportionate
influence on the others and that is an
element of noise because the first
person to speak is not necessarily the
best is not necessarily the most
accurate uh so so are you saying in a
sense that we're disinclined to
disagree well certainly there is a
massive amount of conformity that goes
on and this is where you know otherwise
meetings might go on much longer but uh
and and as it is they G too long but
there is there is Convergence and there
is in in that sense more convergence
than we would want that is ideally the
ideal form for a meeting would be one in
which people to which people come
prepared each with their own
opinion and
and you establish the amount of
Divergence in their opinions and now you
discuss it and now you try to reach
convergence but the automatic kind of
convergence that happens in a debate is
actually not a noise reduction
mechanism when we were working on this
topic we interviewed an organizational
psychologist who worked with the
admissions officers of
universities and he told us the
following story he had come to an
admissions office in large University
where admissions officers would read the
application essays of applicants and
they would grade them and then they
would give the essay with the grade to
another admissions officer who would
make a separate judgment so our friend
recommended of course that they should
make those judgments Independent by
hiding the grade given by the first
officer from the Second Officer so that
these two judgments could be different
and the answer he got was oh that's how
we used to do it but we disagreed so
much that we adopted the current method
and this is a perfect summary of the
trade-off that organizations make
between consensus which they must
achieve at some point and disagreement
which they do have they tend to suppress
dis agreement as best they can in order
to achieve consensus and to be able to
make decisions and what we're saying
here is if you want consensus to be
achieved on something closer to the best
possible answer you might want to delay
the moment when you you achieve that
consensus and to make sure that you get
independent opinions at the beginning of
the process it's interesting that we're
talking about convergence and people
wanting to agree when certainly in
politics what we talk about all the time
is
polarization well
uh we talk about judgments and and we
try to avoid judgments of values and
differences in values so the assumption
is when when you have underr or or
judges they speak for an
organization the organization speaks
through individual
functionaries and you want an
organization to speak in one voice uh
and and noise is a failure is a
cacophony but when it comes to values or
when it comes to politics in a democracy
you
certainly want to allow differences and
Divergence of values and and and you
certainly don't want to impose noise
reduction oh that's interesting no noise
reduction in politics H um so let's just
think about some of the things that this
has thrown up that convergence in a
sense hide well it's a way of avoiding
the fact that there is noise why do you
think institutions like educational
establishments or businesses are
reluctant to confront the idea of noise
Beyond just wanting to get on and make
any decision whether it's good or bad
well I think first they are not aware of
the amount of noise that there is I
think you know every time we show the
results of a noise audit to an
organization or we just share the
results of noise audits performed in
other organizations people are very
surprised we could hear the surprise in
the room when Denny mentioned the 50%
number from the insurance company this
is very surprising so I think the
obvious answer I mean the the first and
most important answer is they just don't
know and that's partly why we wrote the
book really
but in lots of fields you're getting the
use of algorithms to I think about
Actuarial work which is obviously in the
insurance field you know humans used to
do all the risk calculations and now a
proportion will be done by a computer
but they still as far as I can tell ask
humans to make the final judgment is
that because we don't want to hand over
that that power uh it clearly depends on
the topic I mean there is a long history
about 70 years of comparing the
judgments of people to formulas and and
more recently to algorithms that are
generated by Ai and and humans do not
fair very well in those comparisons and
the main reason for human inferiority is
actually noise because algorithms have
and rules simple or complex have the
advantage of being Noise free and that
gives them a real leg up when it comes
to accuracy
but but isn't the obvious Counterpoint
to that that algorithms can make matters
worse because they will have inherent in
them the biases of of whoever wrote the
code they
will although there is no reason why
those biases should be worse than the
biases of the humans again it depends
what the comparison point is you see the
bias of algorithms is a big topic right
it's being discussed everywhere and it
should be because it's real but the B of
algorithms are there because algorithms
are trained on data that is the past
decisions and the past judgments of
humans so what algorithms are doing is
they are the mirror of our own biases
they are not worse what makes the bias
more visible when you actually have an
algorithm is two things first you can
actually run a million decisions into
the algorithms and see how many you know
biased decisions there are which you
cannot do with a human being second the
algorith is Noise free as Denny pointed
out it's very consistent in its biases
so if you train your hiring algorithm
and you tell the algorithm you these are
all the people who have been promoted in
my company figure out what it takes to
be successful in my company and the
algorithm comes back and says you have
to hire men not women is the algorithm
sexist no you
are the reason you hadn't noticed is
because you are noisy in your sexism
even the even the most sexist recruiter
is occasionally going to hire a woman
the algorithm won't do that the
algorithm will say well it's pretty
clear that here to be successful you
need to be a man so the the absence of
noise makes the bias more visible it
doesn't actually make it worse it also
makes it easier to solve if you want to
solve it you can actually design an
algorithm that would be devoid of such
biases so algorithms could make very
good decisions do we want them to that's
a very different
issue yeah when you know algorithms are
biased biased algorithms are poorly
constructed algorithms and typically the
bias enters somewhere in the definition
of what it is that you're using as as a
Criterion for Success so for
example Amazon uh tried to develop an
algorithm to replicate its high
decisions and then that algorithm turned
out the way they constructed it they
looked at people who had been hired or
had been rejected and they looked for
the what distinguished them and then
they found there was a gender bias
because people had in fact preferred men
to women in their hiring and that went
on to the algorithm that's a flawed
Criterion that is when you want to hire
hire properly you should not go by the
previous hiring decisions then you are
guaranteed to replicate the bias but
when you do it properly and then bias is
not a necessary feature of uh algorithm
although as Olivier pointed out the
biases of algorithms are always going to
be more visible because they're going to
be more detectable because they're not
masked by noise whereas the biases of
humans are very frequently M away
noise I'm beginning to think that you
think expertise is
overrated is it a concept we shouldn't
even talk
about expertise in the
field if you want us to say oh we've had
enough of experts we're not going to say
that
no there is an interesting question when
you think about expertise how we
evaluate
expertise and this is that many of the
judgments where we look at experts are
actually
unverifiable that is there are judgments
that we make like long-term
forecasts uh which cannot be verified
and yet so you would think that people
who specialize in that kind of judgments
how how do we know how to
distinguish a
good professional from a weaker
professional and there it turns out that
there are ways for people to emerge as
experts we call them respect experts
because they're experts because they're
respected not because of the quality of
their performance because their
performance cannot be evaluated so there
were expert astrologers and that is very
useful to remember that some astrologers
ERS had the respect of their peers and
they were taken more seriously than
others and and they operated as experts
and what
creates a respect expert is
self-confidence eloquence intelligence I
mean a lot of properties that we want
but they do not guarantee good
performance good performance requires
some verifiable Criterion some way some
feedback about the accuracy of the drug
made now if you are a chess player if
you are a weather forecaster if you are
an investor your expertise can be
measured can be assessed against
objective benchmarks and we can decide
after a while that you are an excellent
or a poor weather forecaster because we
see how accurate you are these are not
the respect experts they are
the experts you can see the outcomes yes
so a fair chunk of the book is actually
a sort of a how-to manual and by that I
mean you sort of say how to detect and
reduce
noise give us some pointers what's what
if I if I decide this is a really bad
thing I want my decisions to be more
efficient to be more accurate what do I
do so we've talked about algorithms and
the basic idea of algorithms is to say
as Denny pointed out wherever there is
human judgment there is going to be
noise if you want there not to be noise
take out the human judgment let's put
that aside because there's many
situations where it's either impractical
or undesirable for either good or bad
reasons to use algorithms and you will
want to use human judgment when you are
going to use human judgment the approach
or the set of approaches we suggest to
reduce noise in human judgment is what
we call decision hygiene and the reason
we use this odd phrase is because the
analogy of washing your hands is apt
here we when we wash our hands we are
not saying oh this was this germ that I
take out and this is this disease that
I've avoided we don't know what problem
we've avoided we just know it's good
prevention we're putting the process
under control and decision hygiene does
that it puts the decision process it
puts the process of judgment under some
sort of control how do you do that we've
talked about aggregating independent
opinions that's a good way to introduce
decision hygiene making sure these
opinions are independent if you
aggregate opinions through discussion as
we pointed out that actually does more
harm than good another way would be to
structure your decisions yet another way
would be to use relative judgments
rather than absolute judgments wherever
you can there's a whole series of things
which taken together help introduce a
little bit more discipline into your
decision
making and I should point out here that
when we talk about noise reduction or
about decision hygiene we had in writing
the book we had organizations in mind
that the book is not self-help for
individuals um I'm quite skeptical about
the ability of individuals to improve
their own thinking but organizations
have procedures they have processes it
is possible although it this is not
typical that there's few organizations
that I know about have designed
processes for reaching judgments or
decisions but we believe that more
organizations should have designs for
making decisions and design that
embodied or that incorporate the
principles of decision hygiene so
organizations have an opportunity that
individuals do not
have at the beginning you you described
the the underwriters at the insurance
agency understand realizing how much
noise there was but is it okay so there
you identified it but is it an expensive
process a difficult process for for for
organizations to undertake do you think
there will be a reluctance to identify
noise well certainly you know in part
because noise is so abstract that as you
can point out to an error to a single
error and it looks like a bias and it's
easy to explain as Olivier was
mentioning earlier noise there is no
single error unless it's a complete
outlier but normally you cannot point to
an eror and say this is noise it takes
more than error it takes the variability
of errors this gives noise that abstract
sort of character that makes it quite
difficult to conceive of and it is true
that when you try to mitigate noise in
an organization you will certainly face
resistance and you will face resistance
which in part is fully Justified because
there is the danger of bureaucracy there
is a danger of imposing procedures that
turn mechanical and that make people
less involved in the judgments that they
make so there is really a tradeoff
between design decisions and spontaneous
decisions and it's up to individual
organizations to find their way in that
tradeoff and before you even get to
noise reduction just becoming aware of
noise is something that some
organizations that many organizations
will resist because noise is
embarrassing you we've talked about one
problem with noise which is that is
costly we've talked about not another
which is that it creates unfairness
there's a third reason why noise is
detrimental which is that it's
embarrassing to The credibility of the
organization if in an insurance company
you become aware that you might get a
quote for $100,000 and the next customer
with exactly the same need might get a
quote for2
200,000 that doesn't reflect very well
on the organization and it's very
tempting to move on and talk about
something else and I can tell you that
this is what happened in the insurance
company they they hadn't known about the
problem and once they were made aware of
the problem I think they forgot it very
quickly but but does that perhaps
reflect that the to come back to this
idea of human agency that the power to
exercise discretion it may be far less
efficient but actually within a company
within a hierarchy it's a necessary
trade-off I'm the top dog I know what
I'm doing and I'm going to tell
you well it's it's certain very tempting
I we we had an interesting conversation
yesterday with a very senior HR
executive who said you know we read
everything that you talk about and it's
clear that it would improve the odds of
hiring the best people but as you point
out yourself hygiene is a bit tedious
it's much more fun to hire people I
like and if that's what you're going to
do that's fine it's your business if I
were your boss I would probably raise
some questions but I'm not so you do
whatever and there is another reason
that really comes up and that judgment
is typically and quite often very highly
fallible so for example in
hiring real accuracy in hiring is
impossible it's impossible because
future performance is not fully
predictable a lot of things are going to
happen on the job that can be known in
advance that are not characteristics of
the individual and that will determine
the individual's performance so the best
that you can do in hiring is quite poor
but you can do worse than that and that
is and and people do but what you get as
a response quite often well if all you
can promise me is that performance will
be quite poor I might as well trust my
God and that's a
mistake